here you mentioned once that are at
least at least once that arts parts will
levitate in the presence of a certain
magnetic field and i'm assuming that's
at room temperature now what makes you
say this where did you get that from
the bismuth magnesium zinc layered
material
it
came in
two sections
uh it was 1996 april
and
i was doing uh
probably
two
two to three programs with art bell
almost every month at that time
and
the first
shipment came was a metal that i got to
alcoa aluminum
to find out what it was because we
figured it was aluminum and alcoa came
back and said where did you get this
it's
99.74
pure aluminum and we don't manufacture
aluminum at this purity
and then
within two or three weeks after getting
the aluminum and my starting the
research and reporting
pretty much pretty regularly with art on
coast to coast and another show we did
called dreamland
came another shipment
and by then i had established with a
professor that i knew
through crop circle investigations at
the university of michigan
we got a second box and it was clearly
more complex
layered pieces silver on one side black
on the other and i called the professor
at the university of michigan and said
we've got a second box
can you take a look at a piece i'm going
to send you and see if we can get
elements
do some electron microscopy all of which
you could do at the university
that led to in my books you see the
analysis
that it was
97.6
a layer
in one of the layers in the silver and
black
and the 97.6
was magnesium
2.4 zinc so it was like an alloy in one
layer that was silver
the next layer
was only one to four microns it was
extremely thin and it was bismuth
so we had
alternating layers
of bismuth magnesium
with
uh
with a magnesium zinc with bismuth
approximately 26 layers making these
silver and black pieces that were maybe
a little less than a quarter of an inch
thick and there were several in this box
as soon as i began reporting what the
professor was finding in terms of the
elements i started getting
phone calls and emails from people
saying
we know from
our research that what you have
is uh going to be from the bottom of a
craft
well it turned out that we had a letter
that came
from a diary of
a
grandfather
who had worked in security at roswell
according to the sender who was a army
sergeant at the time i got to talk with
him on the phone
and he said my grandfather
said this was in one of the crashes in
47
and that he and men were assigned to
ring a wedge-shaped craft
that glowed with light underneath for
about four hours
and essentially that the grandfather
left his
uh relative
this diary saying that he had
done something that would get anybody
else in real trouble he had gone over
and with his own hand had pulled some of
the bottom that was glowing of this
craft
and these are the pieces that were in a
box
and
so we had
the diary
that said that the
black and silver pieces came from the
bottom of a wedge-shaped craft
and
eventually within a very short period of
time of my reporting these various
pieces and questions on the air what
could this be
hal put off
who is a physicist who has worked on
many many ufo-related subjects
he got in touch with me and said linda i
would like to be able to study this
bismuth magnesium zinc material
and
hal put off and
people who are working in semiconductors
i started getting requests
from a variety of different scientists
and then we started cutting pieces of
these originals so that i could send
them out with
releases that everybody would return
what they were studying to me which is
how i kept them for the pieces for
20 years
what i began to
realize that from the people who were
getting the material
and that i was working with
they started talking about we think that
this is
material
that interacts with a field
that would neutralize gravity
that's
that's how all of it very complex series
of tests and reports
evolving into people saying
this material in a field but what is the
field
we never were able to demonstrate this
never but that was the context from
people who had other information that
the bismuth magnesium zinc so now jump
to today in 2022
there are all kinds of reports that have
been emerging in the last year or two
about bismuth
and magnesium
being one of the keys to certain kinds
of skins
that have been verified in ufos
that would have some
relationship to neutralizing gravity
in very specific fields
so that's what's happened from 1996
up to 2022 an evolution
of a whole variety of researchers and
now today
there are people who are willing to say
that
i was looking into the research on this
and i couldn't find any published
research only reports of other people
like hal put off saying well it
it's right it displays anti-gravity
properties however a published piece of
research was by mick west
and he showed that some of the images of
the aluminum art parts
they looked like a fin sheet which is
found in car radiators and around the
year 19
25 i don't know what you're re i do not
know what you're referring to i know
that uh my work with the professor at
the university in michigan was the very
first work
there there was no no other and that was
done we had electron microscope
images
we had uh microscope images we were
doing periodic table uh element
uh
analyses that
led to my uh talking with art and saying
look i would like to find out
from somebody who
where we could do
an um
ion microprobe
which is a very sophisticated instrument
and find out if there is anything in the
magnesium that might be outside of what
is considered normal magnesium on the
earth
and that is one of the elements that had
come up in other ufo stories in previous
years
where a famous case down in south
america there was a magnesium dropped
from a ufo onto a beach and it turned
out that one of the reports was that it
was not earth-based ratios
well that led to art and i uh split the
cost of it i remember it was an 850 bill
and we split it
for me to go to carnegie institute in
washington dc that had at that time in
july of 1996
the only ion microprobe that would be
able to do
a study of the magnesium
and the bismuth
and
the
uh
the
bismuth the magnesium and the zinc
and
it was about a seven or eight hour that
i was there at carnegie institute
and at one point i remember the ion
microprobe uh technical guy said
you know
i don't think
in all of my work here i do not think
i've ever looked at a thin bismuth layer
like this one to four microns
where i did not find also lead atoms
present because on a periodic table
bismuth and lead are right next to each
other and they would normally find some
lead with bismuth and with regard to
that in particular i'm sorry to
interrupt i just want to
hurry this along so mick west and hi i
know you're saying that you haven't seen
the analysis by mick west
and from my reading of it it seems like
what's been displayed in arts parts at
least part of it
is like i mentioned what can be found in
fin sheet and car radiators in the 1920s
and there's a
no the refinement of
if i could just finish
finish on the ion microprobe uh it's the
uh it's the most sophisticated uh
technical
apparatus and we were looking at the
purity or the percentage in the bismuth
layer the zinc layer and the magnesium
layer that's not easy to do
and the ion micro probe that day when i
said it we used it for seven or eight
hours
and that uh when eric howery was the ion
microprobe technician and he was talking
about how the bismuth was pure that he
was not finding lead
and it turned out that the magnesium
had 11
more magnesium 24 than our baseline
magnesium we were using as a comparison
that wasn't enough to kick it into this
is automatically extraterrestrial
magnesium but it was definitely unusual
enough for him he wrote up a report
which i have published in my books
talked about
so the
the elemental compositions of those
layers and knowing that the bismuth was
one to four microns this is very thin
making up these layers
this was uh
hard data
in the period of time that we were
receiving this material in 1996
and that is what i was reporting and
finding in the electron microscope and
eventually at carnegie institute that is
why
hal put off and other scientists became
very interested and that began the next
level of doing agreements where i would
send out some of this magnesium bismuth
zinc to them
to do tests
and
they sending back and saying this is
definitely unusual this is not some uh
deposition as some people tried to say
oh it's just a layered deposition from a
lab
no
that's not true i had a notebook i think
i ended up at the end of 1996 with 119
people and labs that i had gone to
getting information about the bismuth
magnesium zinc and it included a man and
a exotic metals manufacturer in new york
city and when i told him what we had
found at the university of michigan
and in carnegie institute in terms of
what these layers were i remember the
man laughed and said
look
i can tell you
you you can't put
bismuth and magnesium together
they will delaminate
and so
we had uh we had the hard
evidence of what they were made of and
what the layers were and how pure they
were
but metal exotic metal manufacturer
couldn't even recognize how you would
put bismuth and magnesium together in
layers
have you heard of the betterton cruel
process
or has anyone mentioned that to you
say that again betterton kroll so it was
invented around the 1920s
and it was a way and it still is a way
of refining lead to produce similar
amounts of
ratios that have been reported and see
when i watch a show like forensic files
sometimes i see
anyone can do this you can just watch
the show forensic files sometimes you'll
see these experts and they'll say this i
don't know where this came from this is
not even from
this is and i'm an expert in the field
that i've never seen either this
isotopic ratio or this amount of
percentage of elements in it and then
there's some pedestrian explanation
afterward so even experts can
can miss so that's why i'm wondering if
you've heard of betterton crowell
it is a lead analysis process
no it's a refinement it's a refinement
process
that was invented around the 1920s or so
no i mean
you're so far afield
from the fundamental original research
that was done at the university of
michigan
and then carnegie institute
of pure bismuth
in one to four micron layers
and then
zinc
2.4 percent
magnesium 96
percent
given
it has to add up to 100
and that was repeated at carnegie
institute
so the only elements present
in these layers
were the bismuth
thin one to four micron layer
with the magnesium
zinc alternating
very regularly
black
bismuth silver magnesium zinc
a whole series like a torque cake
but only a quarter of an inch high
because the layers the bismuth was so
thin
i understand and those those
what i'm saying is that was the 1996
original hard evidence that would hold
up in a court of law
this is all that is in these layered
metals
so what's happening with those meta
materials right now are they simply
sitting around is the krata agreement
going to produce a public analysis of it
i had uh the medals
working with hal put off and with others
up to
uh august of 2018. so i started those
years in
april of 1996
and by 2018
hal put off had joined with tom delonge
and
lou elizondo and others in that to the
stars group where they
had a goal that they would take
they would have money raise money
to have
exotic technologies
examined and then reported to the white
world as opposed to being constantly
covered up in the black world that was
the concept
and hal uh put off asked me
in uh he'd had the bismuth magnesium
zinc
three different times had written up
his analysis for me that i had reported
and is in my books
and
jacques vallee
in 2017
he had a piece of bismuth magnesium zinc
from me for most of that year
and by then it was because if you go
from 1996 to 2017 to 2018
there had been more and more information
about the role that bismuth might play
in terms of
neutralizing gravity
and so people who had had the bismuth
magnesium zinc 20 years earlier were now
coming back and saying we want to study
it more for x y and z
and by that time how put off had written
to me and said i would like to see a
study
of the bismuth magnesium zinc layered
material
subjected to terahertz frequency
he said i think that if we could
generate terahertz frequency at this
specific level that this could turn into
a lifting body
and terahertz frequency had not even
been in the discussion in the 90s
it came
in those 2017-2018
years
and it was also associated terahertz
frequency had come up in one of the
reports about what might have happened
at bentwaters in england when john
burroughs and others had had encounters
with lights and there was a report that
was finally released in the 2012 2013
period
talking specifically
about ufos emitting terahertz frequency
that probably had to do with
neutralizing gravity but what they had
learned
was that terahertz frequency
could damage human hearts
or organs that had spaces in them like a
heart does at certain levels in
frequencies of terahertz that had never
been reported prior to
2012 and 13.
so coming up
even further to 2017
and 2018.
hal had the bismuth magnesium zinc
wanted to try to see if he could get
terahertz frequency and they had done
tests and they had not been able to
generate the terahertz frequency that he
wanted
jacques valet had a company on the west
coast they said they thought they could
generate the terahertz frequency all of
the year of 2017 jacques had trying and
they couldn't
then by then
to the stars the group that included hal
put off
they came to me and said
we have a variety of interests including
other scientists who
have information and we would like to be
able to work with you as you have with
hal and with jacques and others
and we will have a piece of bismuth
magnesium zinc and we will return it to
you
because we're now going to try to see if
we can
match hal's uh projection that if we got
terahertz frequencies at of this very
high level
it could turn into a lifting body
and long story sh you know long story
short
it's been going through all these
different rounds of research and being
returned to me and i got a call in the
spring of 2018
after to the stars had gotten a piece
that was to come back to me and they
said
we still have not been able to find
a civilian commercial lab that can
project the terahertz frequency at the
level we need
but the united states army is interested
linda we can make you a third party
to the stars
and me and the army
but we need to be able with your
agreement
because all these agreements were with
me to keep returning the pieces to me
over all these years
that
if you want to be a third party
we want to send the bismuth magnesium
zinc layered piece to the army
because they think that they can
generate the terahertz frequency
and i asked them could i think about it
for 24 hours
and i thought
if
anybody
ends up in
an agreement with any of the military
branches of the united states
i could not really foresee
the peace coming back to me
and that's why i propose that they sell
it to me
for all of the costs that i had incurred
from 1996 to 2018 which was considerable
i traveled i flew i took that
so
so a sales
officially on one piece i still have
another piece
went from me to
to the stars
and they delivered the peace to the
united states army which i am assuming
it is still there but they're up to now
as you and i are speaking in january of
2022
i have not heard of any breakthrough
on testing the material
with terahertz and it turning into an
uh
a body that would float
if it has they're keeping it close to
their chest
i personally have no doubt
that a physicist in 2014
at a conference
who came to me and said
with a lot of noise around which was
protective
he said i just want you to know
in the 1970s
at area 51
s4 underground
he said i worked
on the layered bismuth
and
magnesium zinc material
this is in 2014
at s4 for everything i just say the
place that bob lazar
supposedly worked
and and this physicist
showed me proof that i cannot discuss
about what he had done and where he had
been
and he said
i had a piece
of the bismuth magnesium zinc
that was three feet by six feet linda it
came off it was a skin
of a wedge-shaped ufo the diary that
came to art bell and me in 1996
was typed that this was
pulled off
of the bottom skin of a wedge-shaped
vehicle now the physicist is telling me
that he had worked with a three foot by
six foot
piece
and that
its function was to be in parallel with
a pure aluminum remember that was the
first shipment the first shipment we got
in april of 1996 was an aluminum that
alcoa called me on and said where did
you get this it was 97.6 or something
percent pure aluminum and
alcoa said we don't manufacture in this
kind of purity
and the physicist is the one who opened
up for me why
and why these two would have come in the
different boxes from the grandfather
the physicist said what we learned at
area 51 s4
is that it was the pure aluminum that
had iridium
placed atomically in it something we
cannot do
and it had
the pure aluminum was the outside skin
linda the bismuth magnesium zinc layered
was an inside skin
the two skins of the wedge-shaped
objects
then
in some sort of creation or projection
of the terahertz frequency by the craft
with those two skins would turn it into
a lifting body
that was from a physicist
who proved to me who he was
who approached me in 2014. so this is a
complicated timeline
from 1996 getting the physical pieces
the physicist in 2014 telling me what he
was able to study and confirm
at area
51 s4
and then getting to the year 2017 and
2018 where chocolate and hal put off and
to the stars
wanted to study also for the same reason
terahertz frequency mixed with that
material could turn it into a lifting
body but as we speak in january of 2022
no one yet
has publicly published anything
confirming that they have done that
i know that you don't know much about my
background linda i
i'm fairly naive in this subject my my
knowledge is so rudimentary and there's
so many names in so many places it's
difficult for me to contextualize and
make sense so if my questions
are
come across as as rude please forgive me
it's just my
my innocuous naivety okay so well here's
one i sent you my book so you could see
the photographs and on the bismuth
magnitude and i will include a link to
all of the books and what you've sent me
in the description for people who would
like to check them out so here's what
i'm wondering when you sold the
materials to tom delong it sounds like
you were aware he was working with the
government however the government i was
told okay
however we believe the government to be
covering up evidence on this topic so
i'm curious how did you feel about that
and also if i go like this again i'm not
trying to be rude i'm just saying like
okay we have to wrap this up because
there's so we have a significant amount
of ground to cover
but i'll just go like this instead
but i felt like it was unclear on your
side and i wanted to make sure that it
was clear because this is really
important this material is very very
important okay so how did you feel about
that you gave it to someone who was
working with the government when we're
ambivalent about the government
given that they was uh yeah it would it
was a a kind of sad irony
that from 1996
to 20 uh 1918 2018
that i had shepherded
these materials all of those years
and had gone to various labs and had
worked with even steven chu the inventor
of the
super semi-conductor
and people were looking at it for all
kinds of various reasons not just ufos
uh and a lifting body there were lots of
scientists very interested in the
layered combination
and
when
jacques
had been so enthusiastic
and in 2017 thought that they were going
to be able to generate the terahertz
that hal had calculated and they weren't
and hal came back
and said we now think we have a lab it
was very clear
that the test of the terahertz
frequencies at frequencies very near
flipping into the frequency of light
terahertz look at an electromagnetic
spectrum
terahertz
goes right into
uv light
and so it was an issue of how do you
control a certain high frequency of
terahertz
and direct it into the bismuth magnesium
zinc without it flipping into
the light frequency that's as i
understand was one of the problems
and
so if jacques valet and hal put off had
not been able to get the terahertz
frequency test
done
and to the stars comes and says the
united states army thinks that they can
do it now
there is a conflict that i had
shepherded to this material for a very
long time but there was also the realism
i don't have the ability to generate
terahertz frequencies
i don't have labs in which they i can go
into an electron microscopic level
i always was trying to get that to
people who would report results
so
it seemed to me that it was just a final
practical
answer
that i would sell
a piece
keeping another peace i see i see and if
the united states army could solve this
it's my country
this is
for our
united states of america if in fact they
can crack uh what this skin and the two
skins and terahertz frequencies might
produce
that it was had come to sort of the end
of the road of what to do next because
hal put off and jacques ballet
were two scientists that
seemed like they might have a reasonable
chance of getting the the test done
and then it would have been reported
publicly
but
it if i had kept the peace
because i didn't want it going to a
military operation
what would i do with it if
the major researchers
like hal and jacques
had come to a dead end at that point
so that was part of my thinking